bonsoir monsieur mercredi 7 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal votre
route de rendez vous quotidiens
d'information tout de suite on commence
avec le sommaire de votre actualité
locale
les rencontres de la sécurité jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine troisième édition de
ce rendez-vous qui favorise les échanges
entre forces de sécurité et la
population
dans ce cadre le préfet des yvelines a
évoqué la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales au commissariat de
trappes une semaine de la citoyenneté se
tient à magny les hameaux en ce moment
de nombreux rendez vous sont proposés
pour en parler avec nous c'est sylvie go
en charge de l'événement nous
reviendrons avec elle sur cette
initiative à destination des enfants
manie quoi et puis une nouvelle
résidence étudiante à montigny le
bretonneux face au vélodrome
l'inauguration se déroulait ce matin
plus de 300 étudiants ils sont installés
depuis la rentrée et françois bayroux
était à versailles
hier le président du modem et maire de
pau sera l'invité de la 5e édition des
rencontres du jeu de paume une émission
de radio sur l'histoire diffusé le
vendredi 16 octobre de 9 heures à 10
heures par france culture en partenariat
avec le château de versailles
l'enregistrement s'est déroulé hier soir
dans la salle historique versaillaise du
jeu de paume devant une cinquantaine de
spectateurs
françois bayroux a évoqué à cette
occasion henri iv ou encore louis xiv
l'homme politique était au micro de
michael est leader on écoute et on a
parlé d'histoire on a parlé de
de mon ami henri iv on a parlé de ce qui
s'est passé avec les guerres de religion
on a parlé d' identité on a parlé du
château de versailles
on a parlé de l'europe et de la
construction de l'europe et de la vente
sûrs de ce qu'ils avaient construit
l'europe voilà et donc c'est c'est là
qu'on voit que entre l'histoire et la
politique a pas de différence la
politique c'est de l'histoire au présent
et toujours en politique sachez qu'un
dîner débat est organisé par
l'initiative de soixante dix huit jeudi
à 20h à mantes-la-jolie sur le thème
transport public en ile-de-france pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental sera présent ainsi que
yann wehrling porte parole et chef de
file du modem pour les régionales en île
de france
enfin le logement est souvent la
préoccupation la plus importante pour
les étudiants à montigny le bretonneux
une nouvelle résidence sociale étudiante
vient d'être inauguré 300 studios à prix
abordable en face du vélodrome
fanny bourdillon et patrick jacques de
dixmude vous fait visiter les lieux
aujourd'hui sur saint quentin nous avons
18 mille étudiants
et c'est vrai que les logements étaient
très rares on dit sont en train de
rattraper notre retard est aujourd'hui
bien sûr montini cette nouvelle
résidence tout neuf mais déjà
entièrement occupé la résidence le
galibier a été inauguré ce mercredi
matin par la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines christopher
leone régisseur du bâtiment nous fait
faire le tour du propriétaire
la majorité des logements sont des 18
mètres carrés sous forme de studio donc
avec la salle de bains et peut-être
privatif les gammes de prix donc pour un
18 mètres carrés ça va passer entre donc
on est entre 350 et 400 20 euros par
mois livrés fin juin 2015 le bâtiment
est très bien situé en face du vélodrome
et à quelques centaines de mètres de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines
mathieu étudiant en médecine y emménager
ignoble déjà c'est un logement neuf pour
commencer donc c'est vraiment pas mal
donc je suis arrivé ici le logement
était tout neuf et tout est plus qu'à
s'installer il y avait déjà des meubles
prémontées donc des petits rangements
par ci par là
d'autres projets similaires sont en
construction dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
enfin sachez que les 300 studios sont
déjà loués chiens et c'est un sujet
grave chaque année en france 216 1000
femmes sont victimes de violences
physiques ou sexuelles de la part de
leurs anciens ou actuels à partenaires
attrape ce matin une réunion sur les
violences conjugales faites aux femmes
et est organisée dans le cadre des
rencontres sur la sécurité en présence
du préfet des evil mais aussi des
acteurs professionnels les procédures de
prise en charge par le pôle psychosocial
de trappes et des services de police ont
été exposés ainsi que les chiffres qui
montrent une constante augmentation des
plaintes sur ces dernières années
williams elle était sur place
une augmentation inquiétante du nombre
de plaintes pour violences conjugales
faites aux femmes c'est le constat de la
rencontre organisée ce matin à trappes
malgré une meilleure prise en charge et
orientation des victimes grâce au pôle
psychosocial de trappes
une question reste en suspens comment
endiguer les violences sur le pôle
psychosocial de trappes en est passé en
six ans de 200 rendez vous annuel à 15
cents et avec une prévision encore
d'augmentation de 20 % de ces rendez
vous c'est aussi le signe
qu'effectivement cette fonction cette
mission cette intervention et il y a 6
ans ce service implanté au sein du
commissariat permet une prise en charge
immédiate des victimes libérer la parole
pour des femmes souvent réticentes à
l'idée de déposer plainte
il faut établir en fait un lien de
confiance avec la population
et lorsqu'une femme a pu être aidés par
exemple dans le cadre d'une procédure de
violences conjugales
elles en parlent autour d'elles elles
ont fait part à ses amis et si ses amis
sont dans la même difficulté
eh bien elles viennent plus facilement
vers le politique au social
il ya ce discours rassurant à temps par
la psychologue dans un premier temps et
ensuite par rapport aux mesures qui sont
prises d'accompagnement par par par
l'assistante sociale
la victime arrive un peu plus confiants
devant nous et elle est prête je dirais
à aller au bout des démarches et de la
décision approuvée par des démarches qui
n'aboutissent pas tout le temps car
certaines victimes préfèrent souvent
retirer leur plainte
le pôle psychosocial de trappes qui a
déjà fait ses preuves et pour l'instant
le seul dans le département yvelinois et
je vous disais en titre la semaine de la
citoyenneté 7 en ce moment même à magny
les hameaux pour en parler avec nous en
plateau cécile et bigot chargée de
l'organisation de cette initiative
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être venus
alors la semaine de la citoyenneté ce
sont des ateliers des jeux pour
découvrir les institutions locales le
droit des enfants ou encore la laïcité
et parmi les activités que vous propose
il y à un rallye citoyen les jeunes
partent à la rencontre de plusieurs
institutions de la ville
nous avons participé à l'un de ces
rallyes avec des collégiens du collège
albert einstein de la commune regardez
ces sujets des mélanie potier
gendarmerie police ou encore conseil
municipal les enfants mal ni quoi
découvre depuis ce lundi la vie
citoyenne de leur commune
une manière aussi de corriger certaines
idées reçues avec un élu pour mon parti
mairie il me dit souvent c'est ici que
ce vote les lois
enfin les voilà il donc c'est important
de leur faire comprendre que là la
proximité d'une mairie par rapport à
l'assemblée
un autre endroit autre notion le lieu de
mémoire dédié aux victimes des conflits
du 20e siècle
ici ce sont les anciens combattants du
conflit algérien qui échange avec les
élèves ont enfin il a fait la guerre
c'est pour ça et je trouve que issa
représente ce qui se passe avant je ne
suis pas étonné parce que je n'ai jamais
évoqué non plus ce genre de choses avec
mes propres enfants
j'ai survolé ils savent que je suis
blessé de guerre que quelqu'un qui me
manque un oeil mais si tout sur ce bref
passage que les enfants auront fait chez
vous là qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
qu'ils retiennent en fait en définitive
qu'il fasse plus la guerre destiné aux
collégiens mais aussi aux adultes des
ateliers sociolinguistique le rallye
citoyen a concerné plus d'une centaine
de mannequins
alors ça c'est bio cette semaine est
émaillé de plusieurs temps forts il ya
des jeux de l'oie des rencontres
beaucoup d les familles quoi sont
impliqués oui en fait à partir du ce2
jusqu'au en troisième quel est le
message que voulait faire passer aux
enfants avec cette semaine de la
citoyenneté parce que ça s'adresse
justement que vos enfants alors ça
s'adresse un petit peu aussi aux adultes
notamment sur le temps fort du samedi
mais en fait les enfants c'est vraiment
pour leur montrer le respect des autres
et puis pour avoir effectivement une
autre idée des institutions qu'ils
peuvent avoir par la télé ou par
d'autres par d'autres biais alors vous
vous participez à ces rallyes alors
justement quels sont les idéaux
peut-être les clichés qu'ils ont alors
jeune âge c'est des institutions eh bien
ils sont par exemple la gendarmerie ils
sont beaucoup dans la répression il
oublie souvent que les gendarmes sont là
aussi pour les protéger donc il
il voit le gendarme de façon différente
faire exemple comment vous analysez le
fais tu vois des enfants si jeune âge en
collège ou en primaire
enfin une mauvaise image juste de la
police par exemple alors je dirais pas
une mauvaise image mais en tout cas ils
ont peut-être pas la totalité de
ils ont pas l'image totale de ce qui
pourrait enfin de la réalité en tout cas
de leur travail
et puis il ya beaucoup les médias il ya
beaucoup les séries aussi non qu'ils ont
des idées un peu tronqué on va dire
alors pour s'adresser à des collégiens
c'est quand même plus facile mais aussi
vous adresser à des primaires du cm de
haut ces vins comment fait-on par
exemple pour parler de laïcité à des
enfants si jeunes est ce que par exemple
vous vous raccrochez l'actualité alors
la laïcité c'est un peu difficile d'en
parler avec des beaucoup plus 20 des
jeunes de cet âge là on est vraiment
plus tôt dans effectivement dans le
respect de l'autre dans le respect aussi
des institutions qui ils s'intéressent
beaucoup à ce genre de choses aussi au
respect des institutions
c'est quelque chose enfin des éléments
qui sont à véhiculer comme au collège ou
enfin en primaire elle par des cours
d'éducation civique
vous êtes un petit peu leur relais pour
la deuxième édition du zoofest le relais
oui sûrement et puis comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure le fait de d'aller
dans l'institution et de la voir
autrement de voir l'envers du décor ça
permet un peu de désacraliser aussi et
puis de se rendre compte qu'il faut la
respecter
alors par exemple pour la mairie l'a
envoyé dans le reportage que les jeunes
pensaient comme il y avait des lois qui
ont été votées en mairie ce n'est pas le
cas il ya aussi des points qui les
concernent eux directement parce que
finalement les lois savez concerne mais
ça me déprime un peu plus d'adultes
quand vous les années justement à
s'intéresser à ça alors en fait on est
dedans
déjà on l'est on les place par exemple
au niveau des places du conseil
municipal donc on leur explique un petit
peu comment fonctionne un conseil
municipal que c'est pas le maire qui
décide tout mais bien le conseil
municipal dans sa collégialité donc c c
il voit ça de façon différente c'est la
quatrième année que vous organiser cet
événement à la base c'est parti d'un
constat le fait de dormir cet événement
jeudi l'espace a donc du coup il faut
agir il faut organiser cette semaine de
la citoyenneté
alors moi je peux pas trop vous dire
comment effectivement ça c'est ça s'est
mis en place parce que je ne suis là que
depuis un an c'est ma première semaine
de la citoyenneté
mais c'est vrai que effectivement la fin
de cdd et un constat de jeu c'est pas
certaines peut-être de problèmes par
rapport aux jeunes
oui je pense que en fait il fallait
effectivement leur permettre de de voir
le travail des différentes institutions
comme la mairie la gendarmerie ou même
d'autres institutions de façon
différente qu'il puisse se rendre compte
des choses c'est important justement de
faire passer ce message dès le plus
jeune âge je pense notamment aux hausses
et un parce que je constatais peut-être
de la défaite des nets du new des
problèmes dès cet âge là ou pas
forcément des lacunes ou des problèmes
mais en tout cas à cet âge là ils sont
très intéressés et donc je pense que
effectivement le fait de le faire dès le
plus jeune âge ça leur permet de se
rendre compte et de et d'avancer dans la
vie avec le respect finalement c'est un
peu une opération de prévention parce
que on vous parlait notamment ma du
respect de l'autre
vous parlez aussi des dangers de la
route on peut se demander est ce
étonnant quand même pour des enfants et
qui sont très jeunes mais aussi la
consommation de drogue ou d'alcool
opium donc c'est une opération globale
de prévention
oui oui on peut dire ça effectivement et
vous axé sur des points spécifiques mais
apparaît justement le respect de l'autre
alors par exemple les ce2 nous avons
avec la maison de la justice et du droit
un jeu qui s'appelle le quiz papa et
maman ours sur l'égalité hommes femmes
ça c'est important aussi alors c'est
vraiment important vol à égalité homme
femme d'en parler des plus jeune âge oui
oui oui il ya des clichés très exalté
par exemple qu'est ce que vous entendez
aubin le cliché le plus
le plus représentatif c'est maman on
fait la cuisine et papa fait le
bricolage par exemple alors justement
les parents c'est aussi important d
impliquer parce que finalement c'est
comme la deuxième voie est à noter de
l'école il ya quand même peu de
d'initiative où souvent vous impliquez
il y en a une seule il me semble oui
alors cette année on a essayé de
d'innover parce qu'effectivement c'est
difficile d'impliquer les parents
enfin on s'en est rendu compte en tout
cas ces dernières années
et pourquoi j'étais bon set et faisait
un petit alors que justement il devrait
se sentira concerné par ça et bien
écoutez on n'arrive pas trop à savoir
pourquoi on a du mal à les impliquer
en tout cas cette année on a essayé de
faire un atelier théâtre donc au mois de
septembre quatre ateliers théâtre qui a
impliqué et donc les parents et les
enfants en même temps justement pour
monter des saynètes sur le respect de
l'autre et nous avons deux familles pour
cette année donc c'est un début nous et
nous espérons pouvoir en faire l'année
prochaine avec plus de familles et à
l'avenir ce serait une idée de faire
plus intervenir les parents parce que
parfois les parents m'ont quotient près
d'éducation à citoyenne oui bien sûr
évidemment et vous allez faire
intervenir de quelle façon
eh bien écoutez si si le théâtre forum
en tout cas est un succès je pense que
nous pourrons envisager de pouvoir le
développer
il est aussi question à d'histoire dans
cette semaine de la citoyenneté c'est un
travail de mémoire que vous faites
également vous fait participer la fnaca
donc la fédération nationale des anciens
combattants d'algérie
oui dans le cadre du rallye citoyen
qu'ils interviennent sur le carré de
mémoire pour expliquer effectivement aux
enfants l'importance
de la mémoire collective sur les grandes
guerres et sur le fait qu'il faut tendre
à autre chose que le rapport à une
histoire peut-être à des événements
marquants de la commune volet fait aussi
intervenir fin on fait intervenir aussi
d'autres personnes d'autres associations
ils n'ont pas sur ce passion de
l'égalité
justement un filles garçons le droit des
enfants est ce que vous constatez qu'il
ya des lacunes que les enfants à bord de
ce tel est ce que il ya des choses sur
lesquelles ils ne savent peut-être plus
par rapport à avant il ya une différence
entre les générations alors écoutez je
n'ai pas encore assisté donc au à
l'intervention de la maison de la
justice et des droits qui commence
demain donc je pourrais vous dire
l'année prochaine peut-être alors le
jeudi 8 illégalement une centre une
visite du centre de tri de thévalles
grignan l'écologie aussi pour vous un
ami ou c'est important de la faire
mettre au centre de ce faire oui bien
sûr ça fait partie de la citoyenneté le
tri des déchets
enfin le développement durable tout ça
fait partie effectivement la citoyenneté
alors je le rappelle le samedi 2 octobre
c'est le temps fort de la semaine à
l'esplanade à gérard philipe qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra y trouver c'est justement
c'est alors nous pourrons y trouver
d'abord les sapeurs-pompiers qui feront
des interventions aussi avec les jeunes
sapeurs pompiers
nous aurons la gendarmerie le service
enfance qui fera une intervention sur
les droits de l'enfant justement et une
voiture tonneau donc sur la prévention
routière et d'autres intervenants
je pars je vais pas les citer tous là
mais il y en a d'autres
et bien c'est le samedi 10 octobre nokia
magny les hameaux à l'esplanade gérard
philipe
merci beaucoup à cécile bigot fin et
comme chaque année l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lance son festival culturel de la
rentrée pour cette nouvelle édition vous
êtes invités à entrer dans un ami un
univers inattendue sans queue ni tête du
8 au 23 octobre
sephora namani a rencontré une des
artistes du festival
sandrine estrade boulet regarder pour la
9e édition de son festival culturel lu
vs qu université de versailles saint
quentin retient une thématique originale
du 8 au 23 octobre le décalé et le
surprenant à cette occasion sandrine
estrade de boules est exposé sur les
sites de versailles et de 50 ans c'est
plus du domaine effectivement
hallucinatoire
puis effectivement un monde parallèle
quelque chose qui n'est pas
pour moi qui est réel mais qui est dans
le domaine presque de virtuel ou en tout
cas du rêve de l'imaginaire
anciennement graphiste est sorti de
l'école boulle sandrine estrade boulet
est une artiste expérimentale elle sera
toute l'année en résidence artistique à
lui vs cul pour réaliser différents
ateliers et expositions avec les
étudiants j'expérimente donc après
effectivement au départ c'est parti plus
sur la photo et
et le dessin est en fait j'ai utilisé
aussi le digital parce que c'était
quelque part une source sans limite qui
permettait de dessiner sur les nuages
avec une certaine
liberté au programme du festival
ateliers divers et variés cuisine dans
ce jeu de piste
expositions et animations inauguration
prévue avec le banquet des fous samedi
10 octobre à 20h30
et comme chaque semaine vous êtes
habitués maintenant c'est votre rendez
vous du mercredi à ne pas rater on passe
à la chronique avec manip hockey notre
journaliste spécialisé environnement mon
soir à mélanie sensiblement plateau
alors aujourd'hui mélanie vous vous
intéressez aux projets de plusieurs
étudiants de l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement situé dans le parc
d'activités depuis salle où ils ont
inventé une machine de potabilisation de
l'eau c'est ça fait ça ce sont cinq
étudiants de 4e année qu'ils ont créé
ils en ont eu l'idée à la force de leur
deuxième année et vous l'avez dit
florane cette machine sert à rendre
l'eau potable
elle est destinée à un usage individuel
elle peut produire 80 litres d'eau par
heure
ce projet ça représente six mois de
réflexion et de recherche et environ 3 à
4 mois de création écoutez amandine
templiers la présidente de l'association
à l'origine du projet donc a peut être
aussi l'a adapté à loudes rivière que
halo de free c'est une machine autonome
donc en énergie grâce à son panneau
solaire est allé portative donc telle
une grosse mallette
donc là on a eu les stabilisateurs mais
ici ils peuvent être enlevés après les
facilement déplaçable pèse 50 kilos donc
c'est très ça assez léger alors mais une
machine pour rendre l'eau potable mais
ils ne sont que ça existait déjà
oui tout à fait l'eau que nous buvons
elle est potable et elle est issue deux
machines à plus grande échelle
bien sûr puisque ce sont là des usines
il y en a une par chez nous elle est
située à l'ancienne elle utilise
notamment de l'ozone et du charbon actif
en grains pour traiter leurs bleus des
innovations dans cet environnement elles
sont faites tous les jours en janvier
dernier bill gates le milliardaire
américain a fait lui même la promotion
d'une machine capable de créer de l'eau
potable à partir et là je pense même que
ça va vous étonner d'excréments humains
étonnant c'est le mot et la machine de
ses étudiants par contre elle va être
présenté dans le cadre d'une bourse
la totale campus et pour ses pour ce
concours les étudiants ont créé leurs
propres filtres
alors donc la nouveauté si j'ai bien
compris c'est donc ce film a été créée
spécialement pour l'événement mais le
projet ils ont développé dans le cadre
de leur cours de leur enseignement mais
tout à fait dans cette école les
étudiants doivent réaliser un projet
tutoré
certains d'entre eux peuvent être
imposées par l'établissement ce qui
n'est pas le cas de celui ci ils ont
bien sûr un appui technique de leurs
enseignants thierry vaissière et
professeur de droit à l'institut il nous
explique le but de ces projets
l'objectif de toute façon poursuit
décoller ce sujet fait d'imposer au fait
à nos étudiants de poursuivre comme ça
des projets ce qui à la fois leur permet
de développer des techniques de
management et en même temps pas d'avoir
aussi un pied dans le monde
professionnel puisque sur la plupart des
projets sur lesquels on peut bluffer on
a de vrais professionnels avec l'église
ont amené à travailler alors mais
comment ce projet va-t-il se concrétiser
ils ont maintenant plusieurs objectifs à
court et moyen terme
ils vont chercher à insonoriser la
machine et à la miniaturisés le plus
possible pour gagner un maximum de place
il cherche aussi à obtenir toutes les
certifications et surtout très important
pour répondre à l'intérêt humanitaires
ces étudiants ont été très marquée par
le séisme qui a touché haïti en 2010 il
souhaite donc voir leurs machines
installées dans une école haïtienne
d'ici 2016 sa demande bat vraiment des
accréditations d'homologation qui doit
être sûre donc c'est un long parcours
mais qu'on va mener jusqu'au bout la
4ème et 5ème année alors on sait que la
machine fonctionne à l'aide d'un filtre
mind est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
un peu plus
et ben non malheureusement floral je
peux pas vous en dire plus c'est
actuellement top secret les étudiants
vont prochainement déposer le brevet de
leur invention du côté de la bourse le
résultat sera connu le 19 février
le montant peut aller jusqu'à 40000
euros ce qui leur permettrait de
développer leurs machines affaire à
suivre
on leur souhaite bonne chance et
viserait que pour 40000 euros c'est
peut-être un peu normal que ça reste top
secret d'ailleurs il me semble
vous allez voir vous n'avez pas pu tout
filmé la machine vraiment c'est un
projet qui reste vraiment voilà secrète
on en saura peut-être plus si je gagne
la bourse mélanie ce que vous avez le
basket il ya peut-être une future star
de la nba qui vient de saint quentin en
yvelines
retenez bien son c'est tommy segorbe ce
basketteur et demie montant de 19 ans
licencié au club de versailles pourrait
devenir dans les prochaines années
le nouveau tony parker il vient d'être
sélectionné pour intégrer
pendant un an l'université de cleveland
vigneault a été repéré cet été après un
camp d'entraînement à los angeles aux
etats unis
le jeune prodige a pris l'avion
aujourd'hui pour rejoindre sa nouvelle
équipe notre journaliste michael et demi
d'euros l'a rencontrée juste avant son
départ
je réalisais pas forcément josé vieux
comté mais non c'est une blague
j'aurais jamais quand je te crois pas
même jusqu'à jusqu'à la semaine dernière
je réalisais pas encore là c'est dans
les derniers jours je me dis ah ouais
c'est donc trois joueurs dont deux
joueurs là je me dis c'est demain c'est
là que je réalise vraiment cru que je
veux partir
j'ai joué j'ai toujours voulu jouer aux
états unis même pendant moi je m'étais
dit que ouais c'est impossible là je
deviens un peu vieux projet tats-unis
donc je vais rester en france mais c'est
venu comme ça donc après j'oublie que
jamais par l'espoir ont fait jamais su
parer et on lui souhaite bien de la
chance peut-être bientôt sera-t-il en
équipe de france
on lui souhaite en tout cas la fin de ce
journal c'est maintenant rester avec
nous tout de suite vous avez rendez vous
avec sephora namani pour une nouvelle
édition de kiosques le magazine culturel
quant à moi je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée je vous retrouve demain à 18
heures pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
le journal
donc